dans le reste de l'actualité yvelinoise
de nouveaux radars ont été installés sur
l'a12 au niveau de saint cyr l'école le
premier se situe à l'entrée du tunnel de
fontenay-le-fleury en direction de
trappes le second à sa sortie vers paris
s'ils ne sont pas encore en marche
attention aux excès de vitesse dans les
prochains jours cette portion est
limitée à 110 km heure le digitroc fait
escale à maurepas jusqu'à samedi 30
avril ce camion itinérant propose des
formations gratuites au numérique de
1h30 à 3 heures il est de notamment les
participants à utiliser leur ordinateur
leur boîte mail ou encore leur
smartphone d'autres ateliers peuvent
aussi être organisée en fonction de la
demande comme mettre en forme son cv ou
se familiariser avec d'octo libre
prochaine étape poissy du 27 juin au 9
juillet et si les travaux ont pris un
peu de retard la cathédrale de
versailles devrait bientôt retrouver de
son éclat l'horloge a été réparé le
grand orgue et restaurer les vitraux
sont en cours de finition les fidèles
pourront retrouver la cathédrale de
saint louis d'ici cet été